الازمه الاخيره التي تابعنا التفاصيلها
جعلت نتنياهو بعد اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر من
توليه منصبه لا ينال دعوه حتى الان من
البيت الابيض وفقا لمراجعات رويترز
للزيارات الرسميه لرؤساء وزراء اسرائيل من
سبعينيات القرن الماضي وحتى الان زار معظم
الزعماء الاسرائيليين الجدد الولايات
المتحده او التقوا برئيسها في بدايه
رئاستهم للحكومه ما يشير الى استياء
واشنطن الواضح من سياسات حكومته اليمينيه
المستشار الامريكي الاسبق للمبعوث الخاص
للمفاوضات الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
اكد ان الرساله من عدم الدعوه هي اذا
اتبعت السياسات اذا اسرائيل اتبعت او هذه
الحكومه تحديدا اتبعت سياسات مرفوضه فانه
ليس من حقق كيانه نياهو الجلوس في المكتب
البيضاوي العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
تشهد اليوم اهتزازا في قاعدتها الصلبه
القيام المشتركه تضررت وتل ابيب تعمل
خلافه المصالح الامريكيه الانيه بحسب ورقه
عمل مشتركه
للباحثين في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه الدادش
بيت
الورقه البحثيه دللت على الامر باستطلاع
جديد اجراه معهد غالوب للمره الاولى اكثر
من 49% من المستطلعين الامريكيين
المحسوبين على الحزب الديمقراطي يتماهون
مع الفلسطينيين اكثر من الاسرائيليين نسبه
تاييد الفلسطينيين ارتفعت السنه الاخيره
فقط بنسبه 11%